we are in the throes of one of the
biggest tech privacy scandals in a very
long time it's now apparent that the
data analytics firm Cambridge analytical
which worked for the Trump campaign we
learned over the last 24 hours based on
a channel 4 report that they engage in
everything from the hiring of
prostitutes to blackmail setups and
entrapment in order to work for their
clients
Cambridge analytic working for the Trump
campaign in the most recent presidential
election inappropriately gained access
to the data of 50 million Facebook users
the data of those 50 million users ended
up in the hands of Cambridge analytic
and according to some reports has not
been deleted Cambridge analytic
says that they don't have the data it's
unclear Facebook saying we've asked them
to delete it but they haven't and a
completely different story being told by
CA when I heard that please delete it
reminds me of when Hillary went to Wall
Street and told them hey you've got to
cut it out right I'm sure they'll get
right on deleting that incredibly
valuable data about 50 million Facebook
users and the details of this are
somewhat complex they involve a
particular app made by a University of
Cambridge lecturer called this is your
digital life all one word
note no spaces this is your digital life
the app launched in 2014 and the app
through an entity called global science
research took users to a survey these
surveys are common online and the survey
paid them a dollar or two and as most of
these apps do it requested access to
Facebook user information 270,000 users
went ahead and gave the app that
permission but the app was able to also
harvest information of a total of 50
million users most of whom did not give
permission like the two hundred and
seventy thousand users now this is
already bad enough but we've also
learned that the professor working on
this Aleksandr Kogan who ironically
enough might be Russian was actually
working on the behalf of strategic
communication laboratories which owns
Cambridge analytic and who was working
for
the Donald Trump campaign full circle
once again Cambridge analytic ahooo is
dealing with multiple scandals at once
at this point is saying they didn't know
where the data came from that this is
all GSR and Kogan and they weren't told
exactly how they got the data and of
course if they had known how they got
the data they would have turned it down
now does anybody believe that the
company that has no problem
using prostitutes for honey traps and
blackmail entrapment would have a
problem receiving facebook user data if
they knew where it came from having a
hard time with that
Cambridge analytic says in a statement
quote when it subsequently became clear
that the data had not been obtained by G
s are in line with Facebook's Terms of
Service Cambridge analytic deleted all
data received from GSR so that I don't
believe but the big question Cambridge
analytic aside is was Facebook complicit
and if so to what degree and the answer
is we don't know Mark Zuckerberg is now
being summoned by British officials
British elected officials the FTC
Federal Trade Commission in the United
States is starting to look into Facebook
and here's really the bottom line I hate
to break it to you and I don't think
this is going to be news to a lot of
people in our audience this is
Facebook's business model now yeah this
went further but if you listen to my
interview about a month ago six weeks
ago I don't remember exactly how long
ago with Antonio Garcia Martinez who
developed a lot of the Facebook ad
infrastructure if you read his book
chaos monkeys Facebook is fundamentally
a user data firm right it's not a social
network primarily it's not a marketer
it's not a messaging app even though it
does those things and has those features
this is a user data company and Edward
Snowden tweeted something along these
lines when the news broke saying
businesses that make money by collecting
and selling detailed records of private
lives were once plainly described as
surveillance companies they're
rebranding as social media is the most
successful deception since the
Department of War became the Department
of the defense I learned in an early
college communica munication class a
line that goes
something like this if you're not sure
what the product is and you're not
paying for anything it's probably you or
another set another way the product is
your attention what is being bought and
sold is getting your eyeballs onto an
advertisement or a piece of content or
whatever and that is exactly what is
going on here arguably this went further
and we will see to what degree Facebook
was aware of what was going on what did
happen immediately is that Facebook's
stock price dropped when the news broke
this is probably not going to impact
their bottom line directly right
advertisers advertising with Facebook
and we've advertised with Facebook by
the way are doing it because Facebook
has such great user data not despite
that reality yeah this creates a PR
problem for Facebook it's gonna make
regulators want to regulate Facebook but
it's not really a business problem until
the regulation actually hurts them for
the individual user
it's basically cost-benefit right if you
use Facebook I use Facebook Pat uses
Facebook we realize or at least I think
we would be wise to realize that our
data our preferences our likes our
friends our activity it could end up
almost anywhere is that worth it to have
Facebook and use Facebook for a lot of
people it is and there's a broader
question here right what is the
long-term impact of companies having
such accurate and precise data about our
preferences we know that when it comes
to news the consequence of targeting at
the level that is possible is echo
chambers and algorithms that feed our
biases and increase political
partisanship and that gets me to a
really important line from Molly McHugh
Molly McHugh wrote a great article about
this yesterday where she says it doesn't
matter if you don't use your Facebook
feed for politics your Facebook feed is
using you for politics and I think that
that is something we all sort of need to
be aware of here right with products and
services it's ok well they might be able
to really well target accurately target
ads so that you'll buy stuff or sign up
for services with elections it's
potentially
the outcome of who our elected officials
are and thus even if you say I don't
really read news on Facebook I don't
really care about this or that I'm just
down there for the pictures or sharing
stuff with my family even if you aren't
doing politics on Facebook these
algorithms are having political impact I
don't know and I wouldn't even dream of
trying to predict what is ultimately
going to happen in terms of regulation
but this is only the beginning of that
in terms of an FTC investigation and
summons from the United Kingdom of Mark
Zuckerberg and we will see where it goes
but this is this is a major major tech
privacy scandal today's program is
sponsored in part by brilliant if you
watch our Channel or listen to the
podcast yeah you're into politics and
you follow the daily news and you want
to be informed about the world around
you but maybe you also want to dig a
little deeper and on the program we
talked about climate change in taxes and
technology political philosophy to
really understand these issues at a
deeper fundamental level you have to
familiarize yourself with with what's
actually sort of underpinning all of it
and that's math and philosophy and the
hard sciences and social sciences and
that's where brilliant comes in it's a
truly unique and innovative online
learning service which lets you master
important real-world math and science
concepts this includes probability and
statistics logic and problem-solving
renewable energy climate science
criminology you name it and you can get
started right the second by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman the first 200 people who do that
at brilliant org slash David Pakman will
also qualify for 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
slash David Pakman check it out today